[Applaudissements]
on connaît notamment des classes qui ont
investi dans l'aviation qui ont tout
fait pour faire un sort qu'elle est
votée les salles des cultures soient
complètement sûres
et donc en fait 7
ces nouvelles mesures
dans l'air d'être arbitraire ça c'est ce
qui permet de construire le futur et de
continuer à avancer avec des démarches
beaucoup plus réfléchie que justin
aurait on continue à vivre on va au
travail on rentre et on bouffe et la non
il ya quelque chose de plus intéressant
que ça dans la vie comme essai
jean qui vit très bien sans la culture
moi j'imagine passant pas imaginer ma
vie en sachant nourriture sans
tant pis on va quand même jouer certains
lieux déjà se sont dit la même chose on
réapprend des allemandes et
et donc c'est bien que tu dis qu ils les
ont de ses couleurs
magnifiques n'est pas d'accord et épique
que
cette affaire en désobéissent vraiment
puisque c'est contre dieu
[Musique]